respect and reverence for the greatest
generation was mixed with the joy and
honor and pride this morning at the
ceremony marking the anniversary that's
right moments ago President Trump and
French President Emmanuel macron viewed
the former battlefield at Omaha Beach
during a 21-gun salute Anthony Mason is
at the American Cemetery and Memorial in
Normandy where this morning's event took
place Anthony a picture certainly worth
a thousand words throughout the morning
there yeah quite a ceremony Dana and at
the flyover as you can see is still
going on so it might get loud
momentarily but it is a bright and
beautiful day in Normandy nothing like
75 years ago when bad weather threatened
to scuttle the invasion a large crowd
came here this morning to commemorate
this turning point in World War two
there's the flyover
the first Allied troops who landed on
June 6 1944 were followed by hundreds of
thousands who drove German occupiers out
of France and forced the surrender of
Nazi Germany in May of 1945 but the
success of d-day came at the cost of
thousands of lives more than 93 hundred
US service members are buried here at
the American Cemetery in Normandy about
100 survivors from the US and other
countries are here to honor them and
remember the events of d-day many of the
veterans took the opportunity to embrace
both president McCraw and President
Trump who spoke about what was at stake
those many years ago ten thousand men
shed their blood and thousands
sacrificed their lives for their
brothers for their countries and for the
survival of Liberty today we remember
those who fell and we honor all who
fought right here in Normandy they won
back this ground for civilization
president McCraw alongside President
Trump presented the Legion of Honor to
five American veterans to the number of
living World War two vets quickly
diminishing debate today's events serve
as a reminder that the best way to honor
the sacrifice made seventy-five years
ago is never to forget